nous sommes à l'ugc de 51 min pour
l'avant première du film je recommence
et c'est bon là encore une fois nous
sommes là l'ugc de 50 ans les vignes
pour l'avant première du film demain à
tout commence alors dans ce long métrage
qui sortira sur nos écrans donc ce
mercredi à 7 décembre nous aurons
libinois omar sy qui a grandi à quelques
kilomètres de l'ugc de saint quentin en
yvelines
omar je me trompe pas oui c'est exact
mais c'est bien renseignés voilà vous
êtes bien renseigné du ciné j'ai grandi
à trappes et à côté oui de saint quentin
en yvelines
voilà même si désormais vous vivez à los
angeles on l'a vu à quelques instants
pour l'avant première le public
trappistes vous suit avec attention
oui oui longueur je reviens souvent ici
à skywest avec mes films est vrai que
j'ai la chance d'avoir des salles
toujours bien pleines avec un public qui
mazères vins superbes accueille à chaque
fois et je suis très reconnaissant et où
vous êtes également accompagné de gloria
gloria qu'olson ces micro voilà bonsoir
bonsoir gloria alors qu'est ce que ça
fait de jouer avec omar sy c'est super
voilà il est comme ça il est est
toujours drôle il fait toujours des
blagues et il m'a appris beaucoup de
choses parce que c'est mon premier film
mais qu'est ce qu'il a appris il m'a
appris
en fait parce qu'entre les scènes on
rigole beaucoup mais par contre quand on
travaille en fait il m'a appris à me
concentrer
ma prêt à être sérieuses en même temps
que en même temps qu hugo et antoine
voilà le réalisateur filme la violence
des pop corn en direct ou indirect
non c'est bon d'y aller omar ba
comme dit si tu es omar oui gloria
justement les connaissent là parce qu'en
fait c'est toi et stressé bah oui tu es
stressé pourquoi qu'est ce qui va ça
c'est pas du direct non c'est pas du
direct tu vas monter c'est ça c'est pas
didier seban lever toutes les fautes a
bafouillé notre à savannah exactement
une faute arrivait pas dire skywest
toile a redit skywest cgc sais pas s'il
partait mal alors gloria rv on en
parlait quelques instants les commandes
gloria du coup gloria les super elle est
comme ça là comme tu vois là elle est
très mignonne elle c'est une bonne
actrice
elle est très concentré elle apprend
très vite et les elle est très
surprenante mais des gens qui vont voir
le film dont le vin comprendre très vite
on parlait de ce film omar depuis tout à
l'heure
ophélie mme thériault ça pour le film et
allemand voilà le film justement au
niveau au niveau du scénario
en fait je fais ça que j'ai un bouton
comme qu'est qu'on se donne alors ce
scénario du coup il vous a plu tout de
suite dès que vous l'avez lu mais très
drôle tout de suite tout de suite tout
pour faire tous les éléments pour avoir
une très bonne comédie même temps les
allemands pour avoir un bon mélo un beau
un bon moyen de passer de l'un à l'autre
comme ça et après et après avec avec la
mise en scène
dugourd pour avoir le bon équilibre
entre les deux je crois que c'était ça
qu'il fallait heureusement qu'on a vu
une goutte pour pour mettre ça en place
et je crois qu'on a un film qui a un bon
équilibre de tout ça en fait d'un film
ou qui mêle à la fois le rire et
l'émotion un peu roller coaster on nous
a dit souvent donc j'aime bien c'est un
peu c'est ça ouais c'est un peu sa gle
en rien ces questions à gloria parce
qu'elles vivent landes des cleveland
puisque xvi a écrit 20 les venues de
cleveland et tu pose pas de question et
surtout quand comme on est à dans les
yvelines
ça me gêne je voudrais qu'on leur
réserve un accueil digne de ce nom parce
que sinon tu fout la honte
loria gloria oui du coup ce film toi tu
l'a ressenti comme ans du début jusqu'à
la fin
tu as ressenti comme en bas c'est un peu
compliqué de le dire comme ça en direct
voilà c'est ça non mais en fait au début
j'avais en fait hugo il m'a dit en gros
l'histoire j'ai vu le scénario
le scénario c'est ma place et nabeul
away sénat blot comprend tout et c'est
vrai tout est en fait il me l'a dit
après avoir lu le sénat blot après voilà
j'ai des émotions qui au pathé repas et
la voilà et gloria pad alors une grande
carrière selon jana inch'allah mais
voilà c'est son premier film je trouve
qu'elle démarre très bien après ya
évidemment encore des choses à apprendre
encore des choses à faire
il y aura aussi des choix mais en tout
cas à la halle à tous tout ce qu'il faut
pour pour pour pour se lancer
je vous encourage vivement même à
continuer mais ça je lui ai déjà dit et
mais voilà c'est c'est pas c'est pas
s'est passé pas sans travail et sans ce
sera ce sera pas les douanes ont mené
mais comme je sais que c'est déjà une
grande bosseuse
je m'inquiète pas beaucoup après je suis
plutôt superstitieux donc je vais pas
envie non plus de trop dire parce que je
voudrais pas lui porter les dons que je
remets 1,5 pour te protéger mon enfant
une dernière question mars il ya un film
qui va sortir à bientôt sur les écrans
star wars rogue one est ce que vous êtes
un fan de star wars tu te fous de ma
gueule tu es en train de te foutent de
ma gueule non pas l'idée que je jouais
pas le film de demain tout comme ans qui
sera à l'affiché le film veut que je
fasse que la promo pour star wars non
pas pour star wars revient ça marche
bah moody presque
j'ai un bébé sur les bras je quitte pas
sa mère j'ai tout perdu mon portefeuille
j'ai plus de couches et une bleue à vous
parler français ouais ça m'arrive
vous allez me sauver la vie
plaisir on n'est pas à peu près là c'est
pas faux cils changé d'âge il ya mes
coordonnées pro et ça c'est perso non je
te parlerai pas de star wars des malades
star wars va nous vad en même temps que
nous à la fiche je peux pas faire de la
promo pour star wars
non papa pour qu'est ce que tu vois le
film qu'est ce que tu me sens est ce que
ça pourrait vous intéresser un jour ils
ont déjà tourné et vise à 9,1
l'épisode 9 bien sûr ça m'intéresse mais
même où l'opa proposée mais proposeront
pas je pense c'est pas dans vos
objectifs vous connaissez très bien
réalisateur oui mais on ne fait pas ça
se passe pas comme ça tu sais c'est le
réalisateur qui choisit en fait on peut
même si c'est notre copain en appel tu
peux me donner un rôle j'ai vu je ferais
pas ça comme on va terminer à leur
entretien là dessus vous venez avis que
cinq minutes
donc on va terminer là dessus voilà
alors demain tout commencera ce mercredi
7 décembre sur les écrans français
bravo tu as vu j'étais ton c'était ton
baptême justin thomas jane ses mémoires